saviez-vous qu'il y a 2000 ans Bagdad il
y avait déjà de l'électricité preuve il
fabriquait même des piles déjà en terre
cuite dans lequel était plongée une tige
en fer entourée de cuivre isolé par un
bouchon ajoutez de l'acide et ça marche
jusqu'à un vol pas de quoi allumer la
lumière mais ça aurait pu servir pour
fondre des fils d'or sur des objets sauf
que c'est un vrai semblable non il a
technique n'existait même pas à l'époque
cette similitude n'est certainement 15
arts la tige aurait simplement pu être
un support pour papyrus la vérité c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on sait pas à quoi ça
servait mais l'Antiquité est loin d'être
archaïque c'était l'âge d'or des
inventeurs certains avaient même
plusieurs millénaires d'avance alors
découvrons ses inventions beaucoup trop
en avant sur leur temps ces matériaux
disparus de l'histoire
l'assiette Damas avec lui on fabriquait
des lames dont la réputation faisait
trembler les croiser capable de couper
la pierre comme une plume dans les airs
de rester affûté après plusieurs
batailles ces épées ont tenu en échec
tous les forgerons europ on le fabrique
à partir du Woods un acier à très haute
teneur en carbone venant d'Inde il gère
eux-mêmes la quantité de carbone en le
mélangeant avec du charbon de bois
refroidi dans un four pendant plusieurs
jours permettant une diffusion homogène
les lignes blanches que vous voyez à la
surface c'est la sémantique une partie
du carbone se formant pour renforcer la
structure à ce moment là si est fragile
c'est en le forgeant basse température
qu'on lui donne sa résistance l'assiette
Damas est exportée pendant des siècles
avant de décliner et de finir par
disparaître mystérieusement au 18e
siècle les raisons sources de minerais
taries routes commerciales coupées ou
secret trop bien gardé il ne sera
redécouvert que 100 ans plus tard et si
je vous disais qu'il existe carrément
des matériaux qu'on n'a jamais réussi à
reproduire alors que Tibère règne sur la
romantique un artisan demande audience à
l’empereur il a fabriqué un matériau
révolutionnaire intrigué Tibère le
reçoit l'homme lui montre un bol en
verre et le jette par terre à la
surprise générale le bol autorise pas il
se tord simplement comme du cuivre
l'artisan sort un marteau de sa poche et
répare l'objet l'empereur demande est-ce
que quelqu'un d'autre s'essouffler ce
verre l'homme tout fier répond que non
alors Tibère le fait décapiter il était
terrifié à l'idée que cette invention ne
ruine la valeur de l'or et plonge Rome
dans une crise économique cette histoire
on la retrouve dans plusieurs écrits de
l'époque alors est-ce que c'est vrai ou
est-ce que c'est imaginaire mais même là
comment ont-ils eu l'idée du plastique
avant qu'il n'existe une théorie veut
que l'artisan est ajoutée du borax qui
aurait renforcé le verre mais ça ne le
rend pas souple alors y a-t-il vraiment
un type de verre qui nous est inconnu
aujourd'hui ça ne serait pas la première
fois que les Romains inventent des
matériaux oubliés vous êtes jamais
demandé d'où venait la longévité des
bâtiments Romains le Colisée le Panthéon
ou les aqueducs ils ont résisté au
tremblement de terre ou tempête et à la
guerre ça fait 2000 ans qui sont là
toujours debout c'est pas du hasard ils
utilisaient un béton spécial au lieu de
se dégrader avec le temps il se
solidifie c'est en 2013 qu'on en
découvre le secret il mélangeait de la
chaux et descendre volcanique plonger la
mixture dans l'eau de mer pour provoquer
une réaction chimique à l'intérieur du
béton se forme alors deux nouvelles
roches s'imbriquant dans la structure
comme si on rajoutait des nœuds à
l'intérieur en plus d'être solide c'est
plus écolo aujourd'hui 7 % des gaz à
effet de serre viennent de la production
de béton à cause des 1400 degrés à
atteindre le béton antique n'a pas
besoin de ça au lieu descendre
volcaniques on arrive à produire des
matériaux de substitution qui d'ailleurs
dix fois plus longtemps mais c'est pas
encore rentable si à l'avenir on trouve
une solution ben ça sera grâce aux
Romains en parlant de civilisation à la
pointe je vous propose d'en découvrir 13
autres avec le jeu rise of Kingdoms
notre sponsor réalise tes rêves de
conquête en contrôlant dans scène
civilisation comme les Romains la Chine
ou les Vikings j'ai préféré rester
patriotes avec la France et c'est
terrible lanceur de hache grâce à leur
capacité de régénération je guéris 20%
plus vite j'ai réussi à obtenir le
champion légendaire Charlemagne qui me
permet d'envoyer mes unités à l'hôpital
plutôt que de mourir toutes les
utilisation leur spécificité et leur
champion du bonus de récolte à la
construction de quoi construire la ville
de ses rêves à condition de faire les
bons choix technologiques avant que les
ennemis viennent vous détruire tu peux
heureusement te faire aider en invitant
tes amis dans de grandes coalitions vous
voyez cette immense carte ça peut
devenir votre fief à condition de
vaincre tous les autres joueurs qui sont
attention ils peuvent être de bien
meilleures stratège que vous le jeu est
gratuit dispose sur toutes les
plateformes mobiles et PC en crossplay
si on se rajoute un bonus spécial avec
le code Road techo télécharge rise of
Kingdoms le lien en description ces
architectures antiques beaucoup trop
dans le futur Adélie cet objet a l'air
de s'être trompé d'époque un énorme
pilier de fer des années 400 7 mètres de
haut 6 tonnes en fer pur une technique
pétrisée par les forgeons indiens que
l’occident mettra plusieurs siècles à
développer plus impressionnant il est en
super bon état 1600 ans en extérieur pas
une seule trace de rouille pourtant au
contact d’oxygène et d'eau le fer perd
une partie de ses électrons ce qui le
transforme en oxyde de fer hydrater la
rouille pas pour le pilier de délit le
faire utiliser contient beaucoup plus de
phosphore combinés au climat de la
région des périodes très sèches puis
très humides ça a provoqué la formation
d'un mélange d'hydrogène de fer et
d'oxygène une couche d'environ 1/20 de
millimètre qui empêche les échanges
d'électrons toutes les constructions
n'ont pas la chance de rester debout en
2009 à Rome on retrouve les vestiges
d'une tour hors norme datant du premier
siècle elle était équipée d'une immense
salle à manger tournante une pièce en
mouvement au dernier étage d'une tour de
20 mètres de haut il y avait tout un
système de casier roulement à billes sur
lesquels on posait une grande plaque en
marbre le tout mis en mouvement par un
courant d'eau pourquoi faire tout ça un
délire mégalomane de l'empereur Néron la
tour faisait partie d'un complexe plus
grand la Domus Aurea un immense palais
mosaïque pierre précieuse feuille d'or
fontaine intérieure jardin et une statue
colossale de 35 mètres de haut une ode à
la décadence malheureusement
malheureusement la seule représentation
qu'il nous reste de cette salle c'est
sur des pièces de monnaie de l'époque
c'est pas la plus incroyable invention
architectural de l'antiquité voici le
yacha l'ancêtre du frigo inventé en Iran
au quatrième siècle avant Jésus-Christ
conservant de la glace même en pleine
sécheresse les murs sont composés d'un
mélange spécial sable argile chaux sang
blanc 2 poils de chèvre limitant les
transferts de chaleur on disait même que
c'était imperméable à plusieurs mètres
dans le sol les températures sont plus
basses l'air frais entre par des
ouvertures l'air chaud est poussé au
sommet il y a même à récupérateur d'eau
pour rejeter la glace qui aurait pu
fondre juste à côté un cours d'eau qui
servait à fabriquer la glace sur place à
l'ombre d'un grand mur de grandes
cheminées redirigent l'air frais la
révolution industrielle a failli naître
2000 ans plus tôt il y a un monde
parallèle où Sénèque philosophe sur la
condition ouvrière dans d'immans usines
produisant des statues à la chaîne un
monde où Epictète prend le train pour
aller voter et
gros bateau vapeur on parle grec
jusqu'en Chine figurez-vous que ça a
failli se produire lui c'est
Héron d'Alexandrie géomètre et ingénieur
grec professeur dans la bibliothèque
d'Alexandrie dans ses notes de très
anciennes formules mathématiques de
nombreuses inventions avec description
et schéma détaillé il y a de tout hein
design de fontaine de seringue première
porte automatique de l'histoire
fonctionnant la vapeur même un
distributeur automatique pour donner de
l'eau bénite à l'entrée des temples
lâcher une pièce en haut du vase elle
tombe sur un levier ouvrant une valve
l'essence échapper liquide les Grecs à
Torré ces petits automates on en
retrouve jusqu'au 3e siècle avant
Jésus-Christ souvent des mécanismes à
eau admets préférés celui des oiseaux et
de la chouette on remplit un réservoir
d'où l'eau sort par une sorte de sifflet
qui donne l'impression que les oiseaux
chantent en même temps l'ours des vers
sur une coupelle une fois recouverte
elle descend ce qui fait retourner un
hibou au sommet chez iron Alexandrie on
a même des spectacles complexes tout
était relié à une longue corde et un
système de poulie le mécanisme faisait
défiler des petites scènes si vous tirez
sur la corde mais voilà le plus
incroyable c'est la toute première à
machine à vapeur de l'histoire Léo
libyle un grand réservoir d'eau sur
lesquels sont posés deux types de cuivre
qui servent d'axe de rotation à une
sphère qui elle comporte deux sorties
d'air quand on allume un feu sur le
réservoir l'eau se met à chauffer la
vapeur remonte les tubes avec la
pression elle est éjectée à grande
vitesse provoquant un mouvement de
rotation ça pouvait atteindre les 1500
tours minute evidemment c'est beaucoup
plus simple que les machines à vapeur
des trains mais l'idée de base était là
c'est le premier en décrire la
construction mais on trouve des
premières mentions d'un tel mécanisme en
moins 250 ça veut dire que pendant 400
ans les Grecs avaient des machines à
vapeur sous les yeux et personne n'a
développé l'idée en fait les Grecs
n'avaient aucune envie d'optimiser ce
genre de machine pour relation c'est un
moyen d'expliquer les choses pas
forcément de progresser ses inventions
avant tout des gadgets amusants ensuite
faut avouer un le concept était un peu
différent les premières machines à
vapeur de New comen à l'origine de la
révolution industrielle ont innové par
l'utilisation d'un piston grâce à ça on
a plus de transformer la pression de la
vapeur en mouvement mécanique en fait
dans l'histoire des tas de gens ont
inventé des machines à vapeur des canons
de Léonard de Vinci au premier prototype
de turbine automate et à chaque fois
aucune n'attendrait de révolution ça
aurait été peu probable pour les Grecs
vu qu'ils exploité peu le charbon et
leur maîtrise de la métallurgie était
assez imprécise mais avec le bon concept
quelques siècles de réflexion qui sait
on est peut-être passé pas loin de voir
les premières fusées au Moyen-Âge
le premier ordinateur antique 17 mai
1902 les scientifiques explorent une
épave en Méditerranée dedans plus de 300
artefacts statues de marbre bijoux
poterie squelette le vrai trésor c'est
ça un morceau de bronze complètement
rouillé de moins 200 ans avant
Jésus-Christ le mécanisme d'anticitaire
on a aucune idée de ce que c'est à
l'arrière il y a des engrenages une
trentaine taillée avec une précision
chirurgicale lors d’en font à peine un
millimètre de long si tu anomalies ce
genre de mécanisme complexe n'est pas
censé apparaître en Europe avant le
moyen-âge 1000 ans plus tard le monde
scientifique est fasciné tout le monde
cherche à comprendre on dirait un objet
d'astronomie mais il est brisé en 82
fragments le puzzle est impossible à
résoudre il faut attendre l'évolution
des rayons X la possibilité de produire
des images en 3D pour reconstruire
l'objet sans l'abîmer surprise il y a
carrément des inscriptions qui
détaillent son fonctionnement gravés
dessus c'est une horloge astronomique
ultra complexe composée de trois cadrans
montrant la position du soleil de la
Lune et de certaines planètes sans
oublier les phases de la lune les
éclipses à venir les dates des futurs
jeux olympiques tout en suivant le
calendrier pendant 19 ans tout est
actionné par une seule manivelle le
réseau d'engrenage s'occupe de tout le
plus complexe c'est clairement celui de
la lune dedans on y retrouve des
épicycloïdes des engrenages les uns à
l'intérieur des autres ce mouvement
mécanique permet de calculer la position
des astres on considère donc que c'est
le premier calculateur analogique de
l'histoire l'ancêtre de nos ordinateurs
alors qui a pu le fabriquer la
littérature romaine mentionne parfois
Archimède comme inventeur de machines
similaires il aurait même écrit un livre
pour les faire mais on l'a perdu le
problème de cette théorie et qu'il est
mort plusieurs années avant la
fabrication de celui-ci qu'on a retrouvé
donc oui à une époque plusieurs
mécanismes du genre étaient en
circulation on en connaît qu'un pourtant
à l'époque on calculait avec des
tablettes recouvertes de sable ou avec
des cailloux pour compter le temps
n'utiliser d'éclipsydre ou des sabliers
d'eau ça marchait très bien pourquoi un
tel bon de complexité pourquoi l'avoir
fait disparaître de l'histoire rien
possiblement parce que c'était réservé à
une élite extrêmement riche avec le
déclin de la civilisation grecque
l'utilité d'un objet aussi spécifique
était moindre pour certains chercheurs
les horloges du Moyen-Âge ont peut-être
réinventés ce système sans savoir qu'il
existe déjà un millénaire plus tôt
sauver des vies avec des grenouilles en
bronze
grossièrement un sismomètre est un
capteur ultra-sensible capable de
repérer les plus petits mouvements du
sol efficace sur plusieurs centaines de
kilomètres en technologie pareil ça doit
être récent non pas du tout le tout
premier vient de Chine il y a 1900 ans
on le doit à changing brillant astronome
poète et mathématicien le Léonard de
Vinci d'Orient il a fabriqué la première
sphère armillaire qui fonctionnait à
l'eau documenté plus de 2500 étoiles
améliorer le fonctionnement des
clepsydre et même corriger le calendrier
chinois pour qu'il s'accorde aux saisons
à l'époque les tremblements de terre
étaient vus comme des jugements divins
si le pays en était victime c'est parce
qu'il était mal géré être capable de les
anticiper c'était pouvoir évaluer en
direct ce que les dieux pensaient alors
il est arrivé avec ça un énorme vase en
bronze d'un mètre 80 de large tout
autour huit dragons représentent 8
directions dans chaque bouche une boule
et juste en dessous huit grenouilles
prêtes à les recevoir si un tremblement
de terre commence ça fait bouger
l'immense pendule qui se trouve à
l'intérieur le mouvement enclenche une
petite trappe libérant la boule tenue
par le dragon tombe dans la grenouille
provoquant un son dans la direction du
séisme il l'a offert à l'empereur et
l'objet fonctionnait plutôt bien capable
de ressentir un tremblement de terre qui
ne fut annoncé que 7 jours plus tard par
un messager le sismomètre leur
permettait d'envoyer des vivres et de
l'aide le plus rapidement possible
sauvant de nombreuses vies les
technologies antiques sont souvent
mythiques genre les Égyptiens aidé par
les aliens pour construire les pyramides
on trouve ça avec de soi-disant
hélicoptères sur des hiéroglyphes ou des
avions Incas bon tout ça c'est bidon si
les constructions de nos ancêtres sont
six permanente si qui n'était pas plus
bête qu'aujourd'hui les Égyptiens
étaient des bosses en chirurgie ont
inventé le dentifrice le maquillage en
Chine le papier la poudre à canon la
boussole en Grèce 400 ans avant notre
ère Démocrite imaginer déjà le concept
d'Atom maintenant imaginez retourne à
l'époque ancienne avec vos connaissances
d'aujourd'hui quelle serait la première
chose que vous inventerez pour changer
le monde dites le moi en commentaire et
encore merci à rise of Kingdom allez les
amis Ciao
[Musique]